the summer holidays in full swing
the race is now on to vaccinate 16 and
17 year olds before schools return
that's less than two weeks away in
scotland just four in england and wales
an added challenge will be the
resistance among some young people and
parents
the only way i'd possibly want it is if
we weren't allowed to do things without
it for example
socializing traveling nightclubs stuff
like that
i'm prepared to homeschool my children
to not to not go through that and have
the vaccine
um hugo's 15 and that that would be more
of his decision when he's 16 perhaps
do you feel that you've been pressured
yes definitely
those experts advising the government
have been slow in making this decision
and they're recommending just one dose
for now there is no time to waste
in getting on with this now we have the
jcvi advice
on starting that initial first dose in
16 to 17 year olds
then i want us to proceed as fast as is
practically possible
the us canada and france already
routinely vaccinate children as young as
12.
and the health secretary visiting a
vaccine site in bournemouth
is now confident there's the evidence to
press ahead
the reassurance that we can give
actually comes directly from the
clinicians themselves
and they are all at one on this that
this is
a absolutely the right thing to do uh
for all 16 and 17 year olds of course
uh there's no compulsion in this like
all our vaccination offer
teenagers will be offered the fisa
vaccine to match guidance for other
young adults
and in york there was a largely positive
reaction
these guys are mixing at college at
school it's a no-brainer i think
oh yeah yeah i'd definitely be happy to
do it i honestly think they should go
for it
really do i think i should get it
with schools closed some have become
pop-up vaccination sites
there's now a push to inoculate nearly
one and a half million teenagers
before they reopen sally lockwood sky
news